good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 808 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 808 is currently unable to be moved
from its original location as such arm
containment site 27 has been built
around the area in which it was found
SCP 808 is contained within a 6 by 7 by
17 meter containment tank unit is
constructed from 10 centimeters thick
walls of polyvinyl chloride PVC covered
by 25 centimeters thick acoustic foam
furthermore wooden sound dampeners are
constructed three meters from the
container to further insulate the object
these dampeners are susceptible to
regular degradation and as such are to
be replaced by Class D personnel SCP
808s housing area 808 a is currently set
with explosive charges the public cover
story is that the property has been
purchased by the military as a training
area allowing for complete destruction
of the object if required
barring maintenance a 30 meter buffer
zone is to be maintained around the
object at all times once monthly SCP
808s tank is to be opened and the main
body is to be inspected for degradation
if sufficiently degraded a diluted
phosphoric acid sprays to be applied
then the object is to be Power washed
and coated with further rustproofing
agents machinery originally found within
the structure has been removed to a
storage area 250 metres to the southwest
in the event that any unconnected
machinery in the vicinity of SCP ADA 8
begins to operate all personnel are to
evacuate to evac point
as a precaution to repel invaders
automated motions sensitive flame based
defensive installations around the
object will activate in the event of a
site lockdown description as CP 808 is a
mechanical construct standing
approximately 16 meters tall with a base
approximately 5 by 6 meters 30 meters
squared in area the object is roughly
cylindrical in shape the upper three
meters tapering to a point as CP 808
seems to be built primarily of steel and
iron with several smaller brass fittings
randomly placed lengths of cable and
chain are attached haphazardly to the
lower areas with the majority of the
Machine constructed of steel beams and
gears in simple clockwork patterns
components seem to have been taken from
various industrial machinery with no
single source the machinery forming SCP
808 runs constantly with a low grind
despite no apparent power source the
uppermost portion of scp-804 m-- this
portion is covered in gray carpeting and
a white wedding dress giving it a soft
somewhat feminine appearance the effigy
possesses four limbs the upper limbs
appearing somewhat vestigial and the
lower limbs apparently taken it from a
mannequin the face seems to be a speaker
system possibly constructed of copper
while SCP 808 runs a high-pitched whine
is emitted from the humanoid construct
as SCP 808 structure degrades through
rusting or is tampered with for example
attempts to disassemble the object or
through application of force this noises
volume will increase dramatically this
noise will automatically tune to
frequencies capable of causing local
metals to resonate after growing loud
enough approximately 70 decibels non
electronic components of machinery
affected by this resonance will
spontaneously activate
this anomalous activity will cease once
rust has been removed from a CP 808 no
psychological effects have appeared in
those exposed to the sound direct damage
to the humanoid construct has caused it
to emit an approximately decibel scream
killing 2 and deafening personnel on
site as well as causing extensive
property damage no further attempts to
deconstruct or destroy SCP 808 are to be
taken except in extreme emergencies
recovery log SCP 808 is located within
an abandoned Factory in France an agent
embedded as a local city worker heard
rumors of a constant screech in the
local countryside and called in a small
investigation upon discovery of SCP a to
aid within its structure the four
present agents were assaulted by a group
of civilians killed by agents in
self-defense investigation of the
structure has revealed a sect dedicated
to the Church of the broken and God
associated members of the sect were
captured and taken in to foundation
custody documents and paraphernalia
retrieved from civilian residences
revealed that SCP 808 had been under
construction for approximately seven
months and remains unfinished after
being acquired by the foundation
documentation reveals that SCP 808 was
intended to be a musician of sorts in
preparation for the eventual return of
the broken god associated civilians have
since been terminated under the guise of
an attack by a mundane terrorist cell
security fort has since been increased
[Music]
addendum note from dr. bridge judging by
the main structure I'd say that it was
intended to be mobile it has been that
look like beginnings of legs wheels as
well
it is quite concerning that something
the size of a CP 808 has been built
outside our knowledge however I find it
even more disturbing that a cult of the
broken gone grew this large without
alerting the foundation in light of this
recent growth I recommend increasing the
surveillance unknown Church activities
well I have nothing else to say
apart from dr. bridge is right man those
cultists they scare me anyway I think
that about does it for today thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabah Chris all hens I'd Pablo ice 917
Karim el Ashkan we Justin day Thomas
Morin Curie kuma white crew and jayvo
jack crystal spice my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy King modding
and the wanderer thank you all so much
for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volga thank you
you